it certainly is that it to over all that
we talked about this morning because we
did a session here for young scholars on
this that what comes out of Henry the
fifth is that Henry has his genius at
leadership yeah firstly bringing the
future into the present he paints the
picture of how he wants the world to
work or this situation to work or this
condition to work or this relationship
to work he paints it out there and then
he works backwards to make it happen so
bring the future into the present is the
first thing and secondly he has a genius
approach of looking at what the assets
of the French are because he was in the
Battle of Agincourt and turning all
their assets into liabilities and taking
his own liabilities where he's weak and
turning them into assets and that is
something that businesses have now
started to use and it really comes out
of Shakespeare in a genius way and give
you one simple example the 3m company
had a very big project to have a new
kind of glue and the glue worked very
poorly didn't really stick it kind of
stuck but it wasn't a real good glue and
they turned that liability because
they'd spent millions of dollars on it
into a great asset which is the post-it
notes and so but lots of companies have
done that and lots of places and it's
worked very well